[Music]
so
in the cryptocurrency world
yesterday was it yesterday no the fourth
the fourth what day was that two days
ago
uh bitcoin went did it i didn't even
know
that's what jason chen told me my
financial advisor says to buy it right
now
buy it before it goes too high no oh no
he was just telling me to buy it
oh i see for a while he's a big bitcoin
guy got it well
uh in the bitcoin world uh there are
certain wallets and this is like digital
wallets right
yeah filled with bitcoin there are
certain wallets that have
lots of money in them and the fourth
largest wallet
happens to be worth almost a billion
dollars right now
all right wow and two days ago
that account got emptied now oh the
crazy part is this account
was uh dormant since 2015.
no activity whatsoever and and correct
if i'm wrong but like on the blockchain
there's no way to
tie it to a single person right it's
just like it's you just can see if
there's movement yeah
right right and it's no movement um
since
2015 so uh because of the contents
of its wallet a billion dollars the fact
that there's no movement whatsoever
uh this wallet has been passed around
from hacker to hacker
to try and get into the uh the noise
yes now two days ago it got emptied
so the cryptocurrency world blew up and
they're like that's
bad either the guy came back whoever
owns this billion dollars came back and
collected his [ __ ]
hope so or some hacker came in and brat
figured out the password
and took the billion dollars for himself
damn
that is crazy there's no reason why it
was dormant
it's not that long though 2015 i have
accounts that's
probably wait when it when did i buy
2017 so like
three years it's i haven't touched it so
that's not that long true yeah like i
haven't touched our
our actually you know what half my
money's in your wallet
yeah and i haven't touched that so
exactly
so yeah it's i guess it's not uh un uh
unrealistic to have a dormant uh four
five year
account for five years yeah it's since
the inception of bitcoin that would be
like
oh [ __ ] they haven't touched this in
like that so that billion dollars it was
they have that money because of like
playing the bitcoin game we're like
in 2015 when it stopped uh having
activity at that time with bitcoin's
value at that time
it was worth uh 300 million dollars
it wasn't as much billion yeah the
wallet like the the grand total
um i think it was about 300 million
dollars
at that time and uh since then
because of crypto's value it's gone up
to uh well
to be specific 975 million dollars so
it's not quite
a billion that just sounds like a
regular stock that you would have
that because dormant to me just sounds
like it's just money that's sitting
there and nothing's happening
oh no but the the bitcoin value goes up
though
yeah yeah so since the time they they
had
put all the money in or i mean but then
this is like before 2015 though this is
like
since the inception of uh uh conception
of uh bitcoin
uh it could have been 2010 when they
first put their money in so then at that
point it was like maybe like cents for
one bitcoin because i guess for me it
just sounds like this is just what a
normal account does like why did they
target this one is it just because of
the amount of the wallet
because a million dollars is pretty huge
though for one wallet
like now that's not that's not my
largest wallet
in all the bitcoin universe and the
crazy part is now and i'll give you some
dark [ __ ] now so in 2015 it coincides
with
um the lack effect so the activity of
this account
uh coincided with the uh thing
with a thing called silk road in the
morning
now the silk road is a underground dark
net criminal circuit i can't keep up
with these names
uh yeah i know it's a lot so correct um
where
there's murder for hire there's drugs
criminal craigslist
yeah exactly uh maybe even human
trafficking
we don't know we don't know the full
extent of what um the silk road
uh has and does but people
these hackers that are trying to hack
this account believe that this like this
one billion dollar account uh the money
was from
the silk road so i think because of that
there's like a honorable like thing
going on here where it's like
we're taking that money that might just
robin hood robin hood exactly so if it's
attached to the silk road how come it
was dormant for five years
yeah i'm not too sure with like what
exactly happened here but there was a a
company called btc
e and that company went under for
like i guess illegal trading or whatever
long story short
the silk road had had to cut ties to
this company which then cut ties from
this particular uh account yeah
it's like it's a lot of bitcoin [ __ ] i
don't really understand people go to
jail or something
yeah someone got arrested this guy named
uh
something albright where is he where is
he i don't know some guy named eric
albright
wrong article damn that's crazy can you
imagine just waking up one day and
you're like
oh dude my savings and then you're like
oh [ __ ] there's a billion in there now
you didn't even know [ __ ] about bitcoin
and then your friend was like hey buy
this thing and you're like all right
you put like a thousand bucks right yeah
and then like later on like you hear all
this news and you're like oh i have some
bitcoin dude that [ __ ]
like haunts me a little bit because i
remember years ago like
so many years ago i can't remember i
remember telling you guys too my mom was
telling me about
how there's this new thing called
bitcoin and right now for a coin it's
like a hundred dollars
and i was like what my mom she always
gets sucked into some sort of like
pyramid scheme or like some sort of scan
thing so i was like
nah this ain't real and then later on
like years later i'm like [ __ ] i could
have got a bitcoin for a hundred dollars
that's crazy because it's like what
fourteen thousand dollars right now per
coin
dude i could have got it for a thousand
when i first got into it i'm like
nah i'ma buy gold coins and i ended up
buying gold coins and they're both
up but not the way the bitcoin is up you
think it's but you know what else is
great
you funny ass [ __ ] 2015. that
should happen
they said this went dormant in 2015 but
at that point it already had 300 million
dollars in value in it yeah that's crazy
that's not something that you're like
oh like i don't know what this is let's
just see what happens that's like you're
already
like a wealth manager very very
conscious it sounds like it is
connected to some black market [ __ ] so
i'm like what's it so the owner of this
wallet
did they get caught and like they've
been it could be an exchange too
like or like a fund it's like it could
be like not just one person but a
company
right then yeah yeah i don't even know
why it has a negative tie to it though
because especially if it has no
connection to anyone like it's just
people putting like filling in the
blanks negatively right well there is
technology to trace it in some way and
i'm gonna get to it right now so
uh to answer your questions about the
silk road thing tiff uh
silk road itself was brought down so law
enforcement 2013 shut down the silk road
and the owner and operator ross ulbrich
uh
was arrested and in an aka he was known
as uh uh the dreaded pirate roberts from
uh
uh princesses diaries yeah princess
diaries you know what was his hacker
named pirate roberts
diaries you mean princess pride princess
bride yeah
he nicknamed himself oh yeah
[Laughter]
the second one is my favorite well so
he's the owner of the whole site
he got in trouble yeah and so maybe they
were using
this exchange to trade on silk road with
yes okay that makes sense that's what i
that's what i understand from this yeah
and there's a lot of numbers and and
like code names i'm like i don't know
what the [ __ ] any of this means
long story short now uh later on in the
day
on the same day that this account got uh
all the money got taken out yeah we come
to find out that
the u.s department of justice actually
filed a civil forfeiture complaint
against this wallet and took a billion
dollars for itself
what they took it so they were the ones
that took it yeah the us government took
the [ __ ] money
they took it from whoever hacked it or
whoever
they unlocked it uh they unlocked it so
basically
and this i'm gonna read it verbatim so
law enforcement agents use chain
analysis tools and investigative
assistance who knows what that even
means cookies to identify the largest
cryptocurrency wallets with connections
to silk road
the first modern market modern dark net
market
enabling them to generate this lead from
evidence on the blockchain
and basically they seamlessly
transferred uh all this money to a
government-controlled wallet now
that makes so it wasn't a hacker and it
wasn't the guy coming back and getting
his money no no the government was not
hackers trying to hack in with with some
password it wasn't the guy coming back
to get the money
the us government used their powers to
just seize it yeah
that's tight wow jeff bezos
stuff right there that is pretty crazy
yeah so then now
uh what they want to do is because the
whole point of bitcoin was to
avoid any of that kind of [ __ ] like how
did they do that the freedoms the
bitcoins seem to not be
all there anymore because you got you
said that they already rested the guy
that was
supposedly connected to the silk road
right when they shut it down yeah then
couldn't they have
these people in prison and just
interrogation
and all of that and they got it from
them directly so
they might not still be able they might
not still be able to have access to the
bitcoin
world that's true and they they don't
really go into detail as to how they
conducted their
their topics that way right because i
know defeats the whole person because
they could just
[ __ ] just hack through hack through
[ __ ] government hackers is the
closet it's like what the [ __ ] yeah like
what's the point in
all of us investing crazy back to the
mattress baby
so um so basically all the money's been
moved to a treasury forfeiture fund
and um basically uh somebody else is a
billion dollars richard yeah true
yeah the u.s government government is
they need it right now too
so they're going to use the crypto
assets now to
help fund uh terrorism financing
and uh north korean hacking activities
are like not fun
they're gonna fund they're gonna fund
the defense of that they're gonna bring
back the silk road part two
so north korea is gonna try to steal
bitcoin from us and we're just gonna try
to steal it back from them yeah there we
go
yes and it's gonna cost us a billion
dollars to do it
yes they're they're basically using this
while we [ __ ] print out this stimulus
money
yeah there we go oh maybe it's going to
sing i'm too stupid for all this [ __ ]
i know i took it took me a couple hours
to understand everything last night i
was like i'm getting a headache
trying to understand the story you
explain that very well you did you did a
great job
it just sucks like when you learn new
[ __ ] you see how corrupt
every system is and you're just like
[ __ ]
defeated it's so sad you're like finally
a currency
that can't be corrupted yes it's like oh
[ __ ] they were able to take that money
out
that easy exactly there's the powers
that be there's always someone on top
damn this is crazy man i don't know it's
a billion
dollars does that change your view on
cryptocurrency
no because i think some people get into
crypto for that reason
of like oh i'm against the central bank
and i want to
hold value and whatever i'm just looking
at it as like
um kind of like stocks or like oh it's
just another way to make money
yeah like gold or whatever right yeah
i think you can't ever stop corruption
[Music]
sucks
[Music]
uh